if Republicans don't embrace a lot of
the libertarian ideas that Ron Paul's
talking about like monetary policy
individual liberty constitutional
limited government these things should
not be alien to any Republican the new
debate and the Republican party needs to
be between conservatives and
libertarians I am Nicholas be with Matt
Welch of reason and today we're talking
with Senator Jim DeMint of Republican
from South Carolina senator thanks for
joining us Nick Matt's great to be with
you jim DeMint has been a US congressman
from nineteen ninety nine to two
thousand five he's been a senator from
the what is it the Palmetto State I'll
medicine since 2006 and you have
promised to retire at the end of your
current term in 2016 that's exactly
right I really most people stay here too
long the longer you're here the more
you're part of a system unless you
forget now remember about what really
makes the country great so there are a
few exceptions to that but term limits
would fix most of our problems well we
appreciate your candor and we're going
to hold you to that promise okay in 2016
we're talking about your new book now
we're never saving America from economic
collapse which has a foreword by Rand
Paul one of the new senators you helped
get elected through your activism with
the Tea Party and your push for limited
government the first sentence of your
book is says this is insane what is
insane and what are you trying to get at
what's the message of your book first
and foremost the message is this could
be our last chance to turn things around
and I know politicians are they cry wolf
when there's no wolf we talk about
crises all the time but just as a
businessman or anyone with common sense
when the debt is bigger than your
economy and the plan is to keep
borrowing another trillion dollars more
every year there's not that much money
in the world of our we're going to have
to print it it means the value of our
dollar is likely to go down interest
rates will go up so we can't pretend
that this is not here I mean like Greece
did or like Europe is doing it's a very
real problem the other problem we have
is political
you've got almost half of Americans are
getting something from government and
the other half or paying for it and
we're on a track where sixty percent are
getting something from government and
forty percent are paying for you can't
sustain a democracy with that mix and is
that because you feel that that means
ever you know the sixty percent is going
to be voting a bigger and bigger share
of the forty percent hard to win
elections if you're talking about
limited government if the constituents
want more from government and you see
that phenomenon on display in Greece
when the country is going down in flames
there's still people in the street
demonstrating for more government
benefits and so we've got to understand
we're in trouble that we we don't have
much time because if we we are at a
tipping point politically and if we
don't get those folks who are normally
not interested in politics but they're
working and they're paying taxes raising
families we've got to engage them in the
political process this year we can turn
things around but the one of the main
points of the book is we've forgotten
what made America exception we're a
bottom-up country very individualistic
most other I think every other country
in the world was a top down to some king
or dictator or general can I shape
things from the top but we were
different and we were successful because
we began at the individual level let's
talk about the 21st century because in
the book you talk a lot about how this
is the Republicans fault as well as the
Democrats fault what what happened and
when when do you chart to decline then
of going from a bottom-up country to a
top-down country I mean we've since 1950
we've had many more years where the
government ran a deficit than a surplus
the federal government has only grown in
size and scope state governments local
governments what you know what was the
turning point and also what are the
Republicans responsibility for the
current mess well you can you can go all
the way back to the beginning of our
country and the fact that we we didn't
deal with the slavery issue when we
formed the country means we ended up in
the Civil War and Wars tend to call
cause the centralization of power and we
certainly saw that with the Civil War
some beginnings of national pension
plans and benefits
veterans but the real problem probably
started Woodrow Wilson and then you got
into FDR and his programs with where he
created social security which was
supposed to be a safety net one percent
of the first three thousand and from
their own and I track it through the
books the Republican Democrat you saw
all these department started Department
of Education Department of
Transportation Department of Energy and
all of the positive homeland security
homeland security but what happened in
I'm trying to help people sort through
what's the real issue the difference of
opinion in Washington you throughout the
political labels Republican and Democrat
it's the difference of centralization of
power versus decentralization of power
it's a difference of individual
decision-making versus collectivism and
all of the policies now that we're
dealing with that are coming from the
president and the Democratic Party if
it's it's always central control whether
it's health care education the
dodd-frank bill of financial and
Republicans have been guilty of that
we've fallen for that with No Child Left
Behind and Medicare Part D and every
time we have a compromise it's more
government more spending in more debt
and so at some point we have to say not
only do we need to stop spending more
than we're bringing in but we need to
understand what made this country
exceptional and businesses figured this
out about 20 years ago when Japan was
handed us our lunch with their total
quality movement we're dimming and Duran
and others understood pushing
decision-making down to the bottom
individuals coming up with ways to cut
costs and improve quality that's what
works and that's what made our country
great but we've forgotten that and we we
have to turn it around this year because
I'm convinced that more debt I don't
think we can make it more than another
year or two the only thing propping us
up now is the fact that euros doing so
badly so what do we cut right now if
it's now or never what do we do
centralized what decisions do we put on
the individual level what departments do
we cut what big budget items do we cut
now well I've got this whole chapter of
freedom solutions and but first we have
to decide that we need to balance our
budget the reason that our debates don't
go any
where is the president said balancing
the budget is extreme so to debate with
him about where to cut is useless
because he doesn't really believe we
need to I mean he would like to tax the
rich some more even though the the
wealthy in our country pay a greater
proportion of the national taxes of any
country in the world so I don't know how
much more he wants to take from him but
the issue is do we agree that we need to
stop spending more than we're bringing
in so you need to win the argument first
well and you're you're a proponent of a
balanced budget amendment but that's not
even that popular among your Republican
colleagues right all 47 senators
Republican signed not only a balanced
budget amendment but the one that
limited spending to eighteen percent of
our economy as well as require a
supermajority to raise taxes and
eighteen percent is the historical
average of that's where we know the
private sector continues to be vibrant
but there are there are freedom
solutions to first just a flat simple
tax rate would do a lot to create
millions of jobs I mean we've run the
numbers on it with heritage foundation
but that's not spending right i mean
that that would grow revenue it would
grow revenue and but that's got to be
part not raising taxes but growing
revenue but if you we can cut spending
education should be devolved to the
states we haven't improved education
we've heard it the Commerce Department
is does very little to support commerce
a lot of the EPA functions can be
devolved to the states they're already
partially done now and there's a
duplication of decision-making you go to
transportation we take 18 cents out of
every gallon of gasoline sold bring it
up here states have to fight to get it
back we could bring three cents up here
to deal with federal roads let states
decide and we would have better
infrastructure spend less money and
States could make those what about
entitlements and defense spending
because that's that's where the real
money is right so whatever we do with
the entitlements we don't need to cut
the benefits of those who are already on
Social Security Medicare they paid for
it their whole life we've made them
promises but if we made younger workers
give them options of different choices
and I mentioned this in the book first
of all a lot of people who have
alternative
savings for retirement would probably
take a buyout at retirement of Social
Security i would take half of what i'm
supposed to get actually if you were
offered at retirement okay you can you
can have a 125,000 lump sum now or you
can over the next 20 25 years maybe get
250 most people would say I ain't going
to be there I'll take the lump sum and
run and we could save a lot of money but
we could also give younger workers just
401k style social security plans it's
interesting that they call that risky to
actually save the money but but that
would save us money at the federal level
but give younger workers real equity so
that they're not dependent when they
retire I think healthcare has got to be
individually owned we've got to have our
own insurance to go from job to job and
in the retirement you know Paul Ryan's
mention the idea of hey keep your
private insurance and let Medicare just
pay part of it for you most of us would
pay more than we have to pay for
Medicare in order to keep real insurance
because by the time I get to retirement
it's going to be hard to find a doctor
who wants to see a Medicare patient when
you're only five years away from
retirement he talked about dependency
government spending or people getting
money from the government causing
dependency the defense budget twenty
percent of overall federal spending has
increased basically a hundred percent
since 2000 how much of the defense
budget can be cut without hurting
American preparedness or the ability to
protect American lives I'm not sure what
that number is but I do know there's
waste in pentagon spending its it seem
we've identified not waste and only in
the Pentagon but all across the board
I've got a whole chapter on waste that
Tom Coburn opens for me we can find a
lot of that but we have to have a vision
for what we want our military to do and
that's why the last couple of weeks I've
said I want whoever our nominee is and a
Republican Party to listen to some of
the things around Paul is saying because
the debate within the review have it
endure strong no I hadn't either
Gingrich nor Romney
fresh liners happen they're not really
talking about cutting spending oh yeah
you here Ronnie talk about cut cap and
balance he's picked up that plan and
really all of them i think believe we
have to balance the budget run I mean
Ron Paul is talking about a trillion
dollar right oh yeah yeah no here
talking about balancing the budget is is
an easy thing to do I support this
amendment but I'm not going to tell you
how we're going to get well I mean I
mentioned a lot of things in the book
that we need to and there are a lot of
obvious things and not just the waist we
do need to rethink the money we spend on
military and defense I think Ron Paul
does make a good distinction there's a
difference between spinning on military
and spending for defense and the primary
function the federal government is to
defend our country we need to make sure
that we have the technology the
intelligence of the equipment to defend
America from a lot of new threats and if
that is not doable with bases all over
the world we need to rethink house how
spread out that we actually are and I
think we have to demand and our allies I
pay a greater portion of the defense I
mean in fact we're still in Germany we
were there after world war two and we're
still in South Korea where a lot of
places and we may need to be some of
those places for deployment and
protection but I think it's fair to say
let's rethink that and make sure we're
spending money in the right places and
frankly some of our spending is
politically driven because a particular
defense system or ship is built in a
certain congressional district or state
monies allocated not necessarily because
our generals want it but because someone
in Congress wants it those are the kind
of things we need to change but the
first priority of our federal government
is to defend our people and we need to
make sure we do that well we're talking
to you on the evening of the Florida
primary and you didn't endorse this time
we endorse last time Mitt Romney a
couple related questions with that one
just sort of why haven't you an endorsed
what's the thinking but also just get
into the thesis of your book then now or
never are you hearing the Now or Never
argument from the candidates from
especially the two sort of frontrunners
right now Newt Gingrich and Mitt Romney
they don't seem to be focusing as much
you know on exactly this topic and the
pressing issue of the moment that right
I don't hear the urgency that I'd like
to hear at the same time I understand
from a candidate's perspective that you
can't talk about doom and gloom people
need to feel some optimism and I try to
get that balance in the book it sound
the alarm create the urgency but show
their solutions but the point is we can
determine our own destiny for only a
certain period of time and then other
countries and events will determine our
destiny for us so there are things about
all of these candidates i like and i
hope we can eventually wrap but you like
the moon colonies the moon cut no not as
those one of the things that don't we
were just listening to Mitt Romney
singing you can't like that no I didn't
hear that but the things I don't like
the things I like and I want to be able
to say that these this is not
necessarily my guy and I want to hold
them accountable but the big reason I'm
not involved with the presidential race
is I want to let conservative senators
and through the Senate conservatives
fund and one of the things i found is
the people who send us thirty forty
fifty dollars to help elect people like
Rand Paul they're very divided on who
they think the president should be in a
suit every time I say something nice
about any one of them eighty eighty
percent of people who are trying to help
me or mad at me so well talk a little
bit about yeah you were instrumental in
getting people like Mike Lee and Rand
Paul who are big budget cutters in the
Senate you're one of those spokesman for
the Tea Party or maybe not one of the
spokesman but you you know you're one of
the conduits of the tea party is the tea
party still relevant and where is where
has it been it doesn't seem to have the
same visibility does it still have the
same power that it displayed in the
2010-11 no one wants to go to a rally or
protest you given what the Occupy
movements doing its kind of put a kind
of a bad stain on citizen activism
they're still there and no one can speak
for them they're not any one group I you
know I don't like it when folks say you
know I'm senator tea party I didn't I
didn't start the Tea Party but they came
along and they were spouting the same
concern I have this is a very divergent
group of a mayor
I find libertarians conservatives
independence people have never been
involved with politics some recovering
liberals and but they're just concerned
mostly about the spending in the debt in
the growing intrusive government that's
kind of uniting people that they don't
all agree on the social issues they
don't agree on military and all of those
things but they know our country is in
trouble and that's why they're so potent
that they are the United aspect of what
the Republican least Republican party
needs to embrace right now they're still
there they put down their signs I see
all over the country they're organizing
you've gotten a little more
sophisticated but there are thousands of
different groups so you can't say that
this group is doing that it was
interesting all last year everything
they went on in Congress they blamed on
the Tea Party the tea party is not here
they're out doing their own thing and
there's not one thing we did last year
the Tea Party would have supported
because it was bad legislation bad deals
and we spent more money after the twenty
ten election you had a quote to the
effect of you can't be a fiscal
conservative unless you're also a social
conservative that's a little bit
different than what you were just
talking about that people kind of set
aside social issues they're focused on
the urgency of the moment have you
changed your thinking on that or what's
your thought I should have clarified
that because that doesn't mean it to be
a fiscal conservative yet to agree on
all the social issues but one of our
biggest fiscal issue in our country is
dysfunction in our culture and a
deteriorating culture the growth of
dependency well unwed births can are
correlated with poverty juvenile
delinquency drug use high school dropout
and the unwed birth rate has been
basically promoted and paid for by
federal policies I mean we've gone from
below ten percent when welfare was
started to now over forty percent
seventy percent for african-americans
but but all the statistics show that you
cannot participate at least it's
unlikely but that isn't that isn't why
bush and the Republicans I mean you
voted against it but you know push
Medicare Part D I mean that's what's
killing the budget right not unwed
mothers
it's the dependency on government though
if we only took welfare spending back to
two thousand eight levels we could save
over 2 trillion dollars I mean in people
throw up their hands and the number of
people on food stamps now is
extraordinary you've got one in seven
Americans on food stamps but it's hard
to maintain a vibrant culture when so
many people are taking from government
and Sophie were paying into it so but it
is and you see that dependency as the
motive force here I mean you know
because when you talk about a
deteriorating culture on another level I
mean I look at the last 20 years I've
got two kids and I see a great future
for them I mean it's an America that's
more tolerant that's more innovative
that is more dispersed there are there
are stats that look bad if you if you
are focused on marriage and Parenthood
in that sense but all these social
pathologies just well just get one again
it would i'm not trying to make it a
moral issue but it is very much a fiscal
issue a high school dropout which the
highest correlation with a high school
dropout is coming from a broken family
it will cost america about 250 thousand
dollars over the lifetime and if so it's
a fiscal issue but i'm not saying we
need to make it a moral issue or not be
tolerant but but federal policies should
be encouraging the productivity and you
know folks staying in school and we just
now but the federal policy should not
have anything to do with education right
well well federal policy does have it to
do with it now and what i'm saying is if
federal policy with the welfare programs
and encourage self-development
independence if education was more
locally driven where people could adapt
it to the needs of the 40 a big school
choice yeah so I know what federal
government how do you create a welfare
program than say that actually promotes
because you believe in a social safety
net that's provided by the government it
I mean maybe not that's not your best
case scenario but yeah I would prefer
that to be done at state and local level
and I think you could have a whole lot
more volunteer organizations mutual aid
and I think
drag the church's back into it they want
to do it but there have been displaced
and to try to do that from the federal
level has failed and it's hurt our
culture and I don't say think it's
helped people poverty is worse than it
was when we started more people are in
poverty and well but can I and I'm sorry
to bust your chops on this but more
people are technically in poverty as its
defined by the government but I mean
it's clear that if you're in a poor
family now you're better off materially
than you were say being in a
middle-class family in 1970 and you've
got a car you've got a house you've got
air conditioning televisions access to
education access to medicine so it
becomes difficult doesn't it to just
kind of say we've got more poverty now
well yeah we do define it differently
and a lot of our programs like school
lunch you've got in some cases over half
the students getting free lunch now
people are starting to expect these
things but these are unsustainable I
mean if we could afford them it's one
thing if people were moving out of
poverty then they could say it was
working but the point I'm trying to make
it now or never that it's not working in
fact you can make a good case we're
hurting people in some cases by trapping
them in a situation it's hard to get out
of and we need to transition away from
that i'm not saying throw people out in
the street but we can do a better job
helping people we can save money at the
federal level but the bottom line is
this we can't afford to do what we're
doing now and we need to look at how to
change that and we need to get more
people moving from government dependency
and into to work and productivity that's
going to help us kind of grow our way
out of this problem here's a question
for you you know as reason is a
libertarian magazine libertarian
organization and generally speaking you
know totally our readers and the people
who work here or we're interested in a
small limited government that doesn't
spend a lot that doesn't borrow money so
that our kids and grandkids are paying
for what we enjoy now things like that
but then there are the social issues and
so for instance you're very pro-life you
have supported a flag burning an anti
flag burning a man man you support
school prayer a lot of issues that
whether or not they actually affect
people on a day-to-day level are kind of
markers of a different sort of world
how how would you say like why should
libertarians vote Republican especially
given the last time the Republican Party
had the White House and the Congress
didn't they didn't restrain government
or limit government whatsoever so what's
what's the past the new debate in the
Republican party needs to be between
conservatives and libertarians we have a
common foundation of individual liberty
constitutional limited government and we
can rationally debate some of the things
we disagree on because I don't think
that the government should impose my
morals or anyone else on someone else at
the same time I don't want the
government purging morals and religious
values from our society we can find a
balance there and it really gets back to
decentralization but if you want the
government to say I don't have the right
to say something's wrong then someone
had lose the right to say something's
right but the tolerance is going to come
from decentralization and letting people
make their own decisions but we have to
be able to put up with societal stigma
of things we don't like if you want the
government to come in and say hey this
perp this group can't exclude someone
else because they you know if you want
the government to do that that could be
I mean in terms of salek with health
care reform allowing Catholic hospitals
topped out of you know certain must
carry provisions that would provide
either birth control or abortion or
whatever yeah and that's not imposing a
moral belief but it's allowing people to
practice more of a belief and again I
think the common there's a lot of common
ground with libertarians and I can sit
down with with the Ron Paul or Judge
Napolitano and find a lot of common
common ground we may not come to the
same conclusions but frankly on the
social issues we generally agree that I
don't want the government push my
religion of morals are there Democrats
who are also pulling in this direction
because there i mean i'm thinking of
people like Joe Manchin the senator from
West Virginia is pretty good on spending
are there do you find any hope across
the aisle for people who are also
interested in reducing the sauce yeah in
private to folks like Joe and some
others will
hop in a way that they agree with us the
problem is their political constituency
all pushes for the centralization of
power and so too for him to vote for
something for instance that pushes
education back to the state the union's
don't like that because they can control
the things from the federal level it
becomes more difficult as it moves into
some right-to-work states so it's
difficult to get elected as a Democrat
to the United States Senate if you're
not pretty well sold out to the labor
bosses and the environmentalists
Republicans despite what they say we
don't have a constituency like that I
mean the pro-life groups will support
Democrats if they're pro-life NRA
support the Democrats if they're pro-gun
Wall Street gives three or four times
much to Democrats and so to just warren
buffett another billionaire so our
constituency is pretty much individuals
who want to be left alone or be
successful or small businesses but even
corporate America now is pretty much for
the concentration of power that leads to
crony capitalism sometimes they can
increase their market share by a
government action easier than developing
a better product so that's why I think
we're at a tipping point organized
politics is pretty much towards bigger
government self-identified Republican
Republican registration has gone down
even in this which should be incredibly
favorable climate for the Republican
Party and if you look in the in the sort
of exit polls of the first couple of
primary states self-identified
Republican membership is also down but
Ron Paul's pulling in a lot of kind of
independence or people out there as you
look at that those kind of demographics
of the party are you worried that the
rampal block is not going to be a
Republican block I'm real worried and as
a matter of fact I've done a number of
interviews on this book that said if
Republicans don't embrace a lot of the
libertarian ideas that Ron Paul's
talking about like monetary policy
individual liberty constitutional
limited government these things should
not be alien to any Republican but it no
longer makes sense for Republicans to
have the debate between moderates and
conservatives because I'm
wants to spend more money just not quite
as much as a Democrat and when you're
this much in debt I can I can't tolerate
that debate it's not that I'm not
tolerant it's just that it makes no
sense I mean we've got to figure out how
to trim back and divide the role of
government and I think if we're going to
have a Republican Party that can be the
majority party it's going to have to be
very inclusive of libertarians in a lot
of the things they're talking about
we've got to rethink a lot of the things
we're doing and it doesn't threaten me
to sit down and talk to someone who's
got a different view on how to deal with
the drug war of the military if I know
they believe in limited government
decentralization of power individual
liberty we're on the same page and
that's one of the things I talk about in
the book if you have a shared goal you
can debate and compromise and still move
in the right direction but the problem
we have now in Washington is the
Democrats have a different goal they're
the party of dependency because
dependent voters are dependable votes
for them we need to embrace the rest of
America and that's what was so good
about the Tea Party if he went to him
these were not Republicans they didn't
like any political party but they were
libertarians and conservatives and
independence and people of all political
stripes and a lot of people who didn't
have anything to do with politics but
they were united around this idea of
limited government less spending and
debt and that's the opportunity for
Republicans if we miss that and we end
up with a third party then the Democrats
will be the majority party and I don't
know what we'll turn our country around
what are the odds that the federal
government will ever actually pass a
budget again and if they do will it be
less just year-over-year in nominal
dollars then this last year spending I
think you'll see the house pass a budget
like that which begins to take spinning
down I don't think it will be irrational
in the sense that it cuts right away but
it will start that path downward I doubt
if we'll get that budget through the
Senate but we can force a vote we did
that last year President Obama's budget
got a fair vote in the
not one Republican or Democrat voted for
it but we need to make it an issue this
year because first of all you can't get
a handle on your debt if you don't even
have a budget and the fact that you
don't want to show a budget which harry
reid it says he doesn't means you don't
want to show your priorities or where
you're getting your revenue and what
you're spending and we owe that to
America well Senator Jim DeMint of South
Carolina I want to thank you Matt Welch
my colleague of reason we've been
talking with Jim two men whose new book
is now or never saving America from
economic collapse Senator Jim DeMint
thanks very much thanks man